yes thank you very much for the
introduction I already give away too
much of the talk I thank you beforehand
so the genesis of this talk is a
keynotes I was invited to give at the
shower I'd say a few months ago and it
was kind of a closed group it was a
large room but though it was a closed
group there's an opportunity to share it
with the rest of you and to share it
with the rest of the community the basic
idea is looking at these two schools
particularly at the machine learning one
because of their high parameters at the
moment I have worked in both schools
which is unusual and well we'll see what
we can learn today but the specific
issue here is about health care and
we've had two very interesting talks
already in the in this session about
biological applications and health care
has issues around us when it comes to
data and I'm not even talking about the
privacy issue which mean that often
these approaches are more and less
appropriate in different in different
circumstances so the first thing is what
are the buzzwords that we're talking
about so a i-i-i promoted the talk as AI
in healthcare because that's what you
have to do in Berlin at the moment
especially if you're looking for funding
which I am on a separate project we're
not talking about generalized AI today
but you have to understand that there is
such a thing and you have to understand
that AI means many things to different
people
and so that's why I stay away from the
word in the rest of the talk I hope that
said I mean I'm a little bit loose with
the language and if anyone's confused
about when I say big data or machine
learning sometimes it is to fit it on
the slide at the point is hopefully
clear but if it's not asked me and we
can clarify things the biggest use of
these tools today in medicine and in
healthcare is actually in computer aided
decision-making and I'll show you some
examples of that in a minute but this is
really where the computer is as a
support tool for the doctors in in their
practice in their clinical practice
doctors have an awful lot of decisions
to make on a daily basis and it's been
shown time and time again that you're
better at your decision making early in
the day early in your day base
and so whenever they start their shift
they make less mistakes and as the shift
goes on the decision of whether they
want another cup of coffee becomes quite
mentally intense and I mean many of us
have worked in difficult jobs and we can
all somehow translate that but in their
job it's particularly difficult also
because there's always the idea the
patient may die okay so machine learning
largely today we're talking about deep
neural networks of some kind
convolutional networks I'm going to
refer to it as big data approaches in
the talk I understand what big is but we
can discuss it after or whatever
the other approach is the mathematical
approach and so the mathematical
approach is really about bespoke models
statistical models of data sets but an
equation here just to show that I'm
really into math and then the final
thing is something that's new and coming
now and which is called a hybrid model
where you try to take the best of these
approaches so as far as I can see in
academia this is not really a thing
you'll often have a students with a
backgrounds in one of the techniques
operating in the lab that specializes in
the other so they're trying to use that
technique on the same problem sets
but there's rarely a case where a single
convergent outcome comes from mixing of
the two models but we're beginning to
see it and there's an example of a
company here in Berlin that are doing it
so let's start with the pure machine
learning approach so before Christmas
Andrew ings group over in Stanford
published this paper excuse me on the
archive and basically it's a it's a
machine learning model it's a base it's
a convolutional neural network that
looks at radiography and is better able
to diagnose and identify pneumonia as
clinicians are and so this is this is
the cutting edge of actually applying
this in the real world and this is an
example which is only an academic
example and it may well be tweaked to
infinity in order to get it to work
perfectly but it is an idea where you
can hopefully apply this now in other
hospitals around the world and you can
try to make it take an engineering
approach now and roll this out
this removes some of the heavy lifting
from the doctors some this example came
from last week it's it's not so
important to read us but it only it was
three or four days ago Chinese AI beats
15 doctors in tumour diagnosis
competition so they're looking at
different types of humor now and the AI
they've basically trained in multiple of
these convolutional networks and each
one is specialized on a specific type of
imagery and how to identify the tumor
from that type of imagery and then the
combined system basically selects which
model should be used for this particular
data set and puts it through it and
quickly makes a prediction and certainly
and they're their metrics roughly
speaking it's on the level of an expert
that it's it's of a human experts which
is not completely confusing because it's
usually in a human who's training the
data in the first place who does the
training data but they have wonderful
metrics of how it's so much faster than
a human being it's two to three times
faster than they than the human experts
and so on so for me a big data
approaches I think they're methods for
finding statistical correlations in high
dimensional data sets and you take
advantage of a large sample size so
that's roughly speaking my definition
here and that's where I'm going with
with the main part of the talk so what I
want to talk about now are some of the
limitations of using these kind of
approaches on healthcare datasets so
I've shown you now the examples of the
imagery where it's extremely powerful
and useful but why why is it not always
so useful so the first thing is that the
users and by that I mean the
mathematicians the machine learners the
scientists in practice they often
mistake an entity so n here is the
number of data points and D is the
dimensionality in biology when we think
about it D is often very high but then
it's not necessarily informative so you
can record 10,000 different things from
my body you can attach sensors all over
but usually if from any kind of modeling
points of view you're not adalah adding
much data when you're adding
sirs most of the sensors in biology are
typically sensors where it's the easiest
thing that you can clip onto and really
you're trying to use it as a proxy for
an underlying process which has been
explored for 30 years in the lab but
you're doing some kind of linear
readouts the example that I gave this
winter is that we had a flu epidemic
here in Berlin which was particularly
severe and at one point in that flu
epidemic if you went to your doctor and
you said I have a fever
they were already basically saying yeah
influenza for sure what's it going to
add when they start measuring blood
pressure they actually measure your
temperature they look at your sweat so
your sweat response on your skin and all
these other things
heart rates also is elevated during
influenza they didn't need to measure
those in the case of most of the people
and in terms of blood samples forget
about it that was early in the epidemic
before it really got so prevalent here
in Berlin the other thing is n is
severely restricted in biology and this
is much less obvious you kind of think
when you're trained into machine
learning that just turn around the
problem to a problem of gathering data
and then we'll engineer a solution to
that and that's the general approach in
machine learning so machine learning is
extremely powerful at doing its thing
and we just need to get enough and in
there well that works when you do
dealing with traffic to a website you
can get a lot of traffic it even works
with genomic stuff because you can now
sequence an awful lot of genome data
also we don't know what the genome data
really does structurally so it's quite
hard to do anything that's non
statistical with us but ultimately in
biology the N I'm typically used to
dealing with when I work in lab
cooperations is between three and
thirteen three to thirteen data points
so that's really in the bespoke modeling
domain and that's where they're working
in a lab and they have to do experiments
and it takes them a week to get a single
data point so I I have friends who have
PhDs in Experimental Biology
where they gather data every day for
five years and at the end they had you
know two papers each of which had N
equals five and this is a success this
is a big success and please you know
this is not to disparage them it's to
highlight the difficulty of gathering
biological data so but they the issue
that sometimes is mistaken here is that
imagine we're taking my blood pressure
every 20 minutes for the next two weeks
that's an awful lot of data in one sense
but let's be honest for most
applications that's a single time series
so that's N equals one so to get a
population of a million people with that
kind of sampling is much more difficult
you can't say that each one of those
individual independent recordings is is
an individual data point because they're
not independent they're from my body
they were taking 20 minutes apart
there's a strong structure underneath
them so unless you're looking to make a
model of my blood pressure and you just
need a very very long-term recording
from me this is not something where you
you can scale it easily and it's often
we often see this in practice when you
get a PhD student or a master student
working on a project the first thing you
do is you typically lump all the day's
in together and it's only afterwards
that you begin to think oh yeah okay
well those ones that's actually the same
data and actually saw those those
recordings over two weeks for me are
actually a high dimensional data set
rather than rather than multiple
recordings so that's the first
limitation in biology the second one is
the statistical limitation so I would
assume that many people in this room are
familiar with this website of spurious
correlations so the one I chose out
which is random on the day that I went
to the website was there's a very very
strong correlation between us spending
in Science Space and Technology and
suicides by hanging strangulation and
suffocation
it looks very very convincing to me I
have to say but you know I think we're
all grown up enough to know that in
repeated testing in high dimensions you
will always find correlations in fact as
someone who trained in statistics
originally you would be really worried
if you don't so it's really you
need them to be there but then what are
you trying to extract from this so let's
move on the third limitation is one that
I call a limitation of ideology and this
again is we're still looking here at the
machine learning the Big Data approaches
so these approaches have a historical
preference for model free approaches it
comes out of their origin in the 80s and
90s it comes out of what people were
thinking about in computer science at
the time they are wonderful wonderful
techniques when you don't know anything
about the data but when you begin to
know stuff about the data sometimes
there are better approaches so biology
by contrast is largely deterministic it
has many many unknowns we'll probably
never know anything everything about
biology but it is deterministic as far
as we know and so why are we ignoring
the known mechanisms in biology and if
we go a little bit deeper into that
question biological data is often very
noisy it's extremely noisy I I worked
with an experimentalist a couple of
years ago where they were teaching
students and there the result was how
well the students learns on a particular
particular visual task and he told me if
we don't have one student in the group
who actually gets worse then we know
that somebody has faked the data sets so
like that's how critic you lessly noisy
this kind of thing is that one of the
they see a strong trend for learning for
six students and the seventh one just
gets worse and they can't figure out why
it may be an attentional issue there's
many things in the field but I cares by
contrast if you build mechanistic not
knowledge so a model into a statistical
fits it improves the signal-to-noise
ratio enormous Lee and that's something
you should be looking for when you've
got low end and you've got a noisy data
set you need to reduce the
signal-to-noise ratio and so that's
where some kind of model-based approach
is more appropriate the fourth
limitation is one of generalization so
I've been a bit cheeky with the English
here I have an American
a British spelling and the machine
learning papers are written with with
the American spelling so generalization
with a Z so in these approaches
generalization refers the ability to
treat statistically identical data and
that's really important it's all this
has a very very strong foundation in
statistics this field and it's four
identical data sets so when you hold out
data to do a trial later on to validates
whatever you you trained whatever you
whatever model you trains there is an
inbuilt assumption that the holdout data
is statistically identical to the data
that was left behind for the training
set and if it's not you're in trouble
and this is why there was leave one out
analysis and all these kind of things in
the early days before we were able to
scale up so much so what happens if
you've got an outlier that's outside the
training data which is extremely common
in biology
you're not going to gather enough data
to fully constrain your problem there is
no way of knowing where it's going to be
predictors where the output is going to
be predicted and the network is not
going to tell you that this is not
something I've seen before it doesn't
have a fan input filter that says hey
this is kind of weird maybe you should
look at it yourself the other issue
which is slightly more technical is that
for data sets even within the
statistical training data it's not clear
and I know there was a talk earlier
about training in manifolds but it's not
clear that you're actually on a smoothly
differentiable manifolds so it's not
clear that when you have a second point
that's right beside the first training
point that it's actually going to be
smoothly predicted to being quite
neighboring in the outputs until you hit
a non-linearity it with most of our
modern techniques it's reasonably okay
but it's it's really it's really not
clear if you do infinite training data
then it's fine but it's until you get to
infinity you you may have a problem here
and the final issue is one of insights
and this is this is this was mentioned
in one of the previous talks but
experimentalist biologists and medics
they want to know about mechanism and so
these classification techniques don't
really treat you much about mechanism so
they may tell you to take the blue pill
in the morning but they won't tell you
why to take it they won't tell you what
the blue pill does to your body they
just say take it yes or no so they
provide no insight so just a quick
summary that in practice the users often
mistake they the N and the D in this so
then the N is the number of data points
and the D is the dimensionality of the
data in repeated testing and high D you
will always find correlations at least
you should big data techniques
historically have this ideological
preference for model free approaches and
this issue of generalization both
outside the data set but even within it
could potentially be an issue for these
approaches and finally from healthcare
points of view yes we want to make
things better faster we want the black
box just throw it at it and solve our
problem today but on the other hand we
have regulatory requirements we have our
own intuitions and so mechanism is
actually very important to us and
honestly you know I'm in one of the
privileged groups here when it comes to
training these statistical models I'm
middle-aged I'm white I'm from
northwestern Europe this is the training
data for these models when it comes to
health care everybody else is outside
that population and if you have some
kind of rare genetic trait or even a
very common one that just happens to
exist in a different part of the world
you are less well treated by these
models today and we can pay to enroll
more people in the in the studies in
order to get better background better
coverage but I mean you're not there's
only 8 billion people on the planet and
it will be difficult to get that kind of
training data ok so the first solution
in my life was to move away from machine
learning approaches and take pure
modeling approaches instead this is
something I worked on back for about 15
years ago so this is a sports science
issue for fitness testing and you know
you don't have to understand it but the
basic idea is that
you take a blood sample from an athlete
at every workloads and you'd look at
what the blood lactate concentration is
and at some point the blood lactate
concentration shoots up so instead of
following what's almost a flatline it
certainly goes what we would call
exponential and at the time they were
doing this analysis on paper a coach or
a scientist would get the raw data and
planners on graphs and each one had his
own method of analyzing it they all had
roughly the same concept of what they
were looking for but in practice even
for the same coach he would do it
differently over time so we mathematize
did using a number of different
approaches and then we also measured it
as well and so the software for this is
now used in sports science labs
throughout the world and it's basically
the the help that a mathematician can
give in in this applied biological world
very simple mathematically the ultimate
answer for the best way to find the
turning point is probably going to be
the second derivative of a line through
here of a curved line but we went with
other ones as well we went with all of
the ones they had if nominally and we
formalized them precisely how you
calculate them so they're completely
reproducible but basically their idea
was that this is flat and this is curved
and somewhere around here we want to
reliably be able to predict and so that
is now possible using these kind of
approaches but it's very bespoke it's
very very bespoke it's kind of like the
work earlier on the neonatal breathing
it's extremely targeted to one
application it's a well I'd say his
application is better than this one but
it's a one that people have an interest
in and therefore you do is if we go up
the hierarchy of difficulty this is tied
in more to Andres work so these are
neuronal recordings from rats and
basically using it a set of equations
you can describe these this behavior
very easily so you stick an electrode in
a neuron and you record the voltage from
it over time and you see these kind of
these kind of patterns of spiking
behavior of electrical behavior
and so we can fit them very well it's an
optimization problem on an equation that
looks roughly like this and we do it for
experiments and the current process is
that pair experiment you you refit it
and since labs have different setups you
sit fit allow for data from different
labs separately and if we go up the last
step in their hierarchy we can go and do
massive simulations of hundreds of
thousands of neurons and we can do it
quite reliably so this is a thousand
neurons doing activity over time this is
the rough population frequency it's very
tight around one Hertz and there's a
bunch of it complicated physics we can
use which can actually set up this
network so that it fires at this
frequency and so that the average
behavior of all the neurons in the
network is that frequency and we can
even tailor what the what the variance
is around that but most people most labs
I know of in the world including the
most advanced ones are not doing this
they're doing trial and error on this at
the moment so they're they're literally
just tweaking the parameters until they
get to the right place so what's wrong
with these pure modeling approaches the
first is they scale very badly you need
someone with a lot of experience to come
and do it and you have to trust that
they did it correctly because you can't
afford to hire two of them also their
own career is not completely aligned
with this they ultimately want to be
hired as someone important and they come
to your project for three to nine months
and then they leave and this is quite a
strange career trajectory for them it's
extremely laborious and time-consuming
to fit these things particularly the
second one with the neuronal models
they're the neuronal spiking models and
when you try to couple these systems
together because they've been designed
separately they tend not to work
together so you get you get two
different neurons that have been fitted
in the same lab you get the same person
doing the experiments and yet through a
little bit of random variance and a lot
of bad luck although it's become and
it's the main thing that you see the two
models don't fit very well together
and you say oh well maybe there was
something else in the biology and you go
and study a third neuron type and you
connect this up in your network but
ultimately the bigger issue is that you
your original fits are not really
they're not really designed to work
together so you came up with the the
most precise solution but it's not the
most appropriate solution to work in a
network together with other neurons that
have also been fitted and I mean I can't
I can't overemphasize that the
requirement for expert knowledge and
this is just it's just huge so is there
a solution
maybe so there's something known as
hybrid approaches and this is just
coming and from my perspective I'm
seeing it more in industry that I'm
seeing it in academia which is also
quite interesting so the example here is
from a group spun out of the shower I'd
say here in Berlin so they work at the
Berlin Institute of Health which is a
sort of an incubator for the sherry ta
and the MDC and the projection is not so
nice but basically what they do is they
have stroke patients and you put the
patient in an MRI when they arrive in
the hospital this is already done very
rarely this is not done on a wide scale
you've done at the sherry today it's not
done in other hospitals it's done in a
handful of hospitals in Germany but you
you get an image from them immediately
and there's two clinically relevant
problems one is you don't know when the
stroke happened and the other is that
the drug that you give that may be able
to treat stroke kills 15% of the people
you give it to so you have a really
interesting issue of whether to give
them the drug or not
sounds like a classification problem
perhaps and they they have quite an
interesting solution so this this drug
needs to be given early if it's four
hours past the stroke it's probably not
worth giving it to them it may be in
certain cases it's not been well enough
studied but from a safety point of view
because of that 15 percent mortality
rates they've usually the clinical
standard is if it's more than four hour
don't give it to them so what they're
doing is they take the patient and they
scan them immediately and they also scan
them a week later and this right now is
basically the training data and some of
those patients receive the medication
and others do not and I mean that's all
done on clinical basis it's not done to
get data points okay just to be clear
but how their model functions is quite
interesting to me so they do a
structural scan of the brain and they
look at the structure of the
vascularization so where the blood
vessels are the gas stroke is ultimately
some kind of burst blood vessel so it's
a blockage or a burst basically and the
blockage leads to a burst and it's
killing neurons around it it's giving it
sits there starving them of oxygen and
it's applying pressure and basically
they're dying and you want to see if we
give the patient this particular drug
there are they already had their stroke
at this point it may be over by now and
a week from now even if we don't give
them the drug they would be in the exact
same state either way but some of them
could be helped a lot and so the
training data or the the system looks at
first is vascular ization and they do a
simulation based on that so they use
that structure to predict the blood flow
going through the through the different
veins and arteries and some of the blood
vessels but separately they have a
machine learning model and this is
looking at all of the clinical records
of the dancer of the rhythm of the data
of the patient and it's looking at all
of the measures you have anything you
can use to make a decision on and it's
being hooked up also to the MRI image
the actual imagery data and then it's
also being augmented with the simulation
so the simulation is coming out of the
MRI data but you would never have enough
data points enough MRIs to train a
machine learning model to learn this
kind of structural identification of
blood flow so they build it in instead
because we know roughly the physics of
diffusion and they they simulated so
there
in the physics at that point and that's
an input into the machine learning model
at the end of that they combine all the
data points and they make a prediction
of basically what kind of why they do it
is they divide up the brain into voxels
and they say per voxel if you give them
the drug now will this piece be saved or
not from damage a week from now so would
it be damaged a week from now if you
don't give them the drug and will it be
if you do give them the drug and the
doctor looks at a nice image and
basically sees the two difference
comparison outputs and says okay for
this patients right now they did the
damage is quite small but a week from
now it will be a whole hemisphere if I
don't treat them so I'm definitely going
to give them the drug they'll take the
risk but if they if it's going to be a
no difference either way then they don't
give them the drug is the idea but the
importance here from my modeling points
of view is how they augment the data
sets using known physics so they
everything I mean it is roughly speaking
a machine learning model it's just that
they built in some simulations behind
the scenes to give you to give you
better data so I've been kind of fast so
okay I think we have a few minutes my
clock is gone so I just threw in one
last slide and because they're well
they're the brain one was this other
group this is what I'm working on now
so yeah it's gone I'm working on the
immune system and we're trying now to
simulate the immune system but it's
never going to be one of these bespoke
simulation models we're instead trying
to combine the two in a hybrid approach
so we're combining the bottom-up
simulations with the the data driven
approaches and so that's what I'm
working on at the moment and I guess
sorry I kind of killed the ending there
by talking about the clock I'll finish
there
[Applause]
hi thanks a very good talk and I have a
question how was the simulation edit I
mean is it a feature like yeah how does
that work so first of all I don't work
for the group they were kind enough to
share their image with me but my
understanding is I mean they're feeding
in the raw MRI voxel data and they're
basically augmenting it per voxel with
some kind of output from the simulation
so a diffusion measure basically and
it's I think it's a I don't know for
definite but I think it's about six data
points per voxel which are basically
characteristics of diffusion at that
local point and that is fed on top of
the other features exactly at the same
time yeah a single classification okay
thanks
thank you I know no no yes
so thank you for a great presentation in
your experience how does medicine look
at models based on neural networks
taking into account that these are black
boxes so there's no full traceability in
why a model to a certain position is so
that that's kind of one of the things I
want to get across in the talk that
computer aided decision-making is not a
problem as long as you can present it
like this stroke case where you show
visually best of our knowledge our
prediction is that in this voxel it's
going to be damaged if you don't give
them the drug but if you do give them
the drug it won't that one's okay
because it's so far away from our
biological understanding of the system
but and and it's also giving them at
least the illusion of power in the in
the in the dye in the decision-making
process but no in most cases there's a
huge issue here and I mean personally I
I don't trust black box models for most
medical issues I think they're I think
they're classifiers and if you can
phrase it as a classification problem
then it's not a problem and you should
use these methods but I mean for most
clinical decisions it's not a
classification decision it's that's step
one and then there's a what do we do
about us and it's usually it I mean it's
usually a hundred classifications
feeding into a decision process and
that's what the clinician is doing so
yeah so you're saying if a system like
this is part of a larger decision
support process and it should be fine so
I mean yes for that example for the
stroke example and for the pneumonia and
so on but could you also maze away the
imagery where you get rid of the
radiographer I'd say someday probably
but right now no way in hell because
these systems are being trained up in
individually and so I mean if I need
just a slightly different angle
my body maybe I'm missing an arm and it
just totally screws up the the image or
something of my chest you need you need
a human there to interpret that for now
right great - thank you thank you now
there was one of the friends know we
need the audio for the video yeah thanks
for great talk you met you referenced
the talk on the respiratory machines
there the question of interpretability
arose there as well and one of the
questions at the end had to do with
using tree-like structures in their
learning and a way of you get an opinion
on that I think they're cool I like them
they lead a lot of data though so I
think for the neonatal data there's
probably going to be enough data
available at least if you try and I mean
so this is something that's not so well
appreciated I mean there was the bad
news about IBM recently that Watson may
not be as good as they claims which was
not a very well kept secret but decision
systems for symptom based classifiers
for for diagnosing patients I recall
reading that in the 90s they already
surpassed clinicians so you know
computers are really good at some of
this stuff you just you just want a
human there because there's so many
other things there's the human being who
doesn't present things the same way
because their husband beats them you
know because there's something else in
the data set that confounds basically
and the neonatal it's not clear to me
whether you can have enough data but
probably in that case you could because
it's such a simple data but know that
the trees are great but just I mean it
is really an issue of n here can you get
enough data points but in terms of being
able to point at stuff I think I think
it's really useful yeah thank you beside
you so just one comment it's like from
our perspective as clinicians I think
it's almost like machine learning would
help us to
remove some of the primitive motors we
have I think because in in in clinical
care most of us hold such a primitive
motors of from coming from the 19th
century and we make our clinical
decisions based on these models and
people will just stuck to it
because that's what they learn that
that's what they pass on and and III
think we had some very nice examples
like have you heard of the hero which is
a machine learning based sepsis sepsis
classifier which is just looking at like
heart rate variability and it actually
detects you know predict sepsis whether
a patient is septic or not and it works
better than the nurses so there are I
think some very very new very new
products here and also programs which
are developing so there was one down the
bank left but yeah
thank you great job thank you not
necessarily a question but maybe more as
a comment that we were talking about
pushing the end to the big but this is
also not necessarily a solution because
if you have a float way of collecting
data then it just reinforced your
certainty in you know patterns being
present in the data put the end to the
you know to the big site so with big or
small and you should be trying to give
the model your priors or the knowledge
that you are certain about so or maybe
to make it a question do you agree no I
agree I think that's a good note to end
on
[Applause]